Hey traders, this is Mike from Mortflows
and welcome back to my channel. In
today's video, I'm going to talk about
delta, specifically uh min max delta and
how you can use it in your trading. All
right, so before we begin, you know, if
you've been enjoying my videos, be sure
to subscribe to the channel, hit the
notification bell so that whenever I
post a new video, you'll be uh notified
of it so you come and watch it. All
right, so delta, right? So in order
flow, don't confuse orderflow delta with
options delta. um orderflow delta is
different what it does or what it is
it's the net difference between the
aggressive buying and the aggressive
selling in a bar right you know the
markets trade in a two-way auction so
there's trading taking place on the bid
there's trading taking place on the
offer
and net net if there's more aggressive
trading to the buy side you're going to
have positive delta if it's more
aggressive
selling taking place in the bar you're
going to have negative delta Okay, so
every bar is going to have delta. It's
going to be positive or negative. And
generally speaking, whenever you have a
green candle, you have positive delta,
and a red candle, you're going to have
uh negative delta. But of course,
there's going to be times where you have
a red candle, like in this case, that
has positive delta or a green candle
like this that has a negative delta.
Okay? And I've made videos explaining uh
why that occurs and and their importance
in orderful analysis. But what I want to
spend some time talking about today is
the numbers that you're seeing down at
the bottom of uh the chart. It's the uh
max delta and the min delta. And what
the max delta is, it's how strong delta
was in a bar. So
if for example this green candle right
here, it's got max delta of
347. It's telling you that at its
strongest point, the positive delta was
347. Okay. So then like in this red
candle, excuse me, we got the min delta,
which is the opposite of max delta is
how strongly negative delta was in a
bar. It's - 103. Okay, so it's telling
you at one point the strongest uh net
selling was minus 103 contracts. Okay,
so now that you understand what max and
min delta is, you got to take it a step
further and understand why it's
important or why is it not important.
Okay, so again, you know, there's going
to be times where some bars have zero
max delta or zero min delta. You're
never going to have an instance where
you got a zero max and a zero min
because then you'd have uh no delta. But
you can see on this red candle here, the
max delta was just positive3. It's
colored white. And that just tells you
that in this bar, the strongest
aggressive buyers were were just three
contracts over the net aggressive
sellers. That does not mean that there
was only three contracts bought
aggressively. It's telling you the net
difference at its strongest point, sort
of at its apex. Just like on this green
candle, right, it had max delta of 347,
but the min delta was zero. It's also
colored white. is telling me that in
this bar,
right, net aggressive selling was never
in control. Think of it as a tugofwar,
right? You have the two sides of the
rope, right, with the, you know, the
ribbon in the middle and it goes back
and forth, back and forth until one side
wins. What it's telling me in this case
was once this bar opened, net aggressive
selling was not present. This is net
aggressive selling, not just net net
selling. Okay, it's the difference
between the aggressive selling and the
aggressive buying. Okay, so from that
what we've discovered in our years of
research is that there are times
where the max delta or the min delta is
very small. Okay. And so what we do on
the orderflows trader software is we
color it white. You know, other software
um you can color it whatever color you
want. Um or you know in the old days we
just used to watch the footprint chart
and see oh you had zero or you had three
you know you got to make a cutoff right
when you create a program so here this
one's four that's why it's not coloring
cuz I use uh a threshold of three so
it's either got to be if it's going to
be max delta it's going to be 0 1 2 or
three or if it's min delta 0 -1 -2 -3
like here's minus5 okay um and depending
on the market that you're looking at say
you you know, if you're a market like,
you know, um, bonds, right, that trades
a lot of volume, um, you're going to get
fewer bars that have zero max or zero
min. That's not say that you won't. You
can see there's one here and there's one
here. But on a thicker market, you know,
that trades thousands of contracts, uh,
sometimes tens of thousands of
contracts, uh, you know, per bar, you
might want you might want to, uh, extend
it, uh, out. Okay.
Now, so how can you use this in your
trading? Well, what you want to do is
you want to one, you got identify it
either with your eyes or you could use a
tool, right? On orderflows trader, now
in the new version of orderflows trader
8, we've made it uh plottable. And not
only plotable, but here, let me just add
it on. We draw a zone out from either
the top of the bar if it's
bearish or from the bottom of the bar if
it's bullish. shows here you can see
small min max delta and you can see
there's uh delta threshold that you
could put in here. Um three would be you
know it deals an absolute. So if you put
three it's going to be either 0 1 2 or 3
or 0 - 1 -2 - 3. If it's a if it's a red
bar it's going to look at 0 - 1 - 2 - 3.
If it's positive it's going to be um 0 +
1 + 2 + 3 in the delta. It's the delta
threshold. Okay. So, what you're going
to do then you're going to click apply,
right? And it's just going to come up on
your chart and you're going to be
highlighted every time it appears. Okay?
So, you can see this bar here has got
the bearish signal on top, right? It
says uh so I know that there was very
small within three contracts of max
delta, right? Just as over here there
was zero max delta. Over here there was
zero max delta. Then obviously the blue
is the bullish ones. You got zero min
delta right over here. You got zero min
delta. Um zero min delta. It's not
showing on this bar because this bar is
a dogey candle which open and close at
the same price. And generally in dogey
candles, even though there's volume that
trades and things happen, since there's
no direction, I don't really put much
weight into it. That's just me. Um, I've
just found that in order flow analysis
for me personally, dogey bars, um, you
know, just as they would be on on
regular
candlesticks generally signal indecision
because the bar opens and closes at the
same price.
Now, that's nice now that you know where
these areas, these bars that are coming
in with small min or small max deltas.
But how can you use it in your trading?
Well, you know, people going to say,
well, you know, what's the point? you
know, you got bullish, bullish, bullish,
but it's bullish signal coming up here
at the high, you know, bearish, you got
a couple bad bearish signals here. Okay.
Well, there's a couple ways you can do
it. one, you know, when you get the
signal, if you're just looking at every
single instance of it, um, you know,
it's a sign of momentum in a sense
because if you have very small, in this
case, in this red bar here, you have, in
this case, you have zero max delta, you
know, the min delta is dominant. You
know, the aggressive sellers are
dominant and you're going to go with
that just as in this candle here, right?
you've got zero min delta and it's all
max delta basically 347 we close at 343
right so you know the momentum is up but
what you got to do is you got to wait
for the bar to close confirm that and
then wait for the next bar to open okay
that's why you wouldn't be taking a
short here or short here however you
know what we've done in order flows
trader 8 to even make it more effective
in your using usage rather you know
since this is a momentum signal you want
to be trading with momentum right is now
what we've added did is we've added a
momentum filter
onto this indicator if you will. Uh so
let's just find it here small minmax
delta and you see here enable momentum
strength filter. Okay now this when you
enable this it uh is linked to this up
here this global setting momentum
strength which is three which is the
average one is the weakest momentum sort
of not say the weakest momentum but the
first signs of momentum six would be the
strongest momentum. Okay. Um, you know,
I mean, you could go stronger than that,
but what we found is, you know, six is
is about as high as you really need to
go. Um, so then you just click
apply and then you're going to see the
difference, right? It's going to be only
showing you the
signals coming in with momentum here.
Here. So, it's removed one here. It's
removed one here. or the sell that was
here, the sell that was here to take out
a buy earlier just because the momentum
wasn't there yet. Okay? So, if you're
trading momentum, you know, that's a
great way that you
can use the small minmax in your
trading, but you still want to wait for
the next bar to confirm it, right? Still
go in that direction just so you
wouldn't be taking this trade here
because the next bar trades below it and
then the next bar after that, the second
bar after that is right at the same
level. Okay? Obviously, this one you
wouldn't take. This one would be a nice
one, right? So, it's a nice move here.
And you're going to see same thing. No,
no. You know, you take this. This is a
nice short here, right? You know that
this, you know, you got the small max
delta, right? One, right? You got the
signal coming in
here. Okay. Next bar opens. Just wait
for it to break that low, right?
5664. Trades down over the next 10
minutes. Basically, down to 54.
Okay. Starts working its way back up. A
little bullish trade here. Not the
greatest one, but then a nice another
bearish trade coming in here. And you
know, you could use
this in any market that you trade with
orderflow, whether it's E- Minis, uh,
MNQ,
DAO, gold, bonds, currencies, um, you
know, even the commodity markets like,
you know, grains and and things, you
could still use that because, you know,
every bar is going to have delta. It's
going to have max delta. It's going to
have min delta. And you really what you
want to understand is who's really in
control of this market, right? If and if
somebody's just clearly dominating the
market, clearly in control of the
aggressive buying or aggressive selling.
And again, it's not just one person.
It's it's
the what you want to call it the the
herd, you know, so to speak. um you know
once if everybody understands what's
going on in the market and what I'm
saying is
when there's times to follow the
cumulative herd so to speak right if
everybody's is all of a sudden thinking
I got to get short and they start
getting short not just the retail
traders but the institutional traders as
well that's the direction you want to be
trading in just as if you know all the
big
traders all of a sudden say you know
what I got to start getting long Right?
And then how can you tell? Well, they're
all just leaning in one direction.
They're they're leaning to the
aggressive buying side. That's the side
you want to be trading on. Okay. So,
that's the small minmax tool and how to
use the
momentum
filter to filter out the signals that
you can trade with. All right, everyone.
So, I hope you've enjoyed this video.
Don't forget to subscribe to the channel
and hit the like button, okay? Okay. And
I'll see you guys on the next video.
Take care.